We need to deduct -2x ^ 2 + 4x - 1 from 6x ^ 2 + 3x - 9.
I recommend that you pause the video and see if you can solve it.
Okay, now let's do it together.
I can write it like
6x ^ 2 + 3x - 9
minus this expression here,
so I'll put it in brackets,
minus (-2x ^ 2 + 4x - 1).
What can we do here?
Well we can uncover brackets,
being careful with this negative sign.
Once we do,
we will get 6x ^ 2 + 3x - 9,
this will not change, so it's still the same.
6x ^ 2 + 3x - 9.
But after I uncover the braces here,
the negative of -2x ^ 2
is plus 2x2.
So this will be plus 2 ...
I will leave a little more space.
Plus 2x2 and then subtract,
and then we have the negative of plus 4x f ...
Now I'll get 4x.
And then the negative to minus 1,
or the opposite to minus 1, which is plus one.
I just unveiled the brackets here.
Now I can bring together the members who
have the same degree of h ...
So I have a member x ^ of the second degree,
here it is 6x12,
here I have a member 2x ^ 2,
so I can put them together.
6x2 + plus 2x2.
If I have 6x 2 and then I have 2 x 2,
how many squares do I have?
Now I will have 8x ^ 2,
or 6x per square plus 2x square.
We collect the coefficients 6 and 2,
to get 8x ^ 2.
Then we can collect members with x.
You can look at these as first-degree members,
3x ...
We have 3x
and then we have -4x,
so that 3x - 4x,
if we have three of something and get 4,
now I will have one of these things minus
or could you say that the odds,
3 - 4 makes -1.
So now I have -1h.
I can write it like -1x,
but I can also write it just like -h.
This is the same as -1x.
Finally, I can go to free members.
Draw 9 and then add 1.
You can ask, "How much is -9 plus 1?"
Well this will be -8.
This will be -8 and we're ready.
Something that might seem interesting to you,
is that I had a lot here too
I pulled another one.
And I notice that I received a multi-
and this will always be the case.
If you think of the multitude of all the many,
if you just think about the crowd ...
Let me write it in neutral color.
So if we look at the crowd here
of all the many
and if you take a multi-
you can imagine that this is the purple multipurpose, for example.
So this is a multi-faceted,
let us call it p from x.
This is p from x,
p of x and then you got another multiplayer,
this one here, let's call it,
I do not know, we can call it q of x,
q of x, just to be interesting.
That's q of x, that's right.
And if you apply ...
in this case we applied the subtraction action.
If we apply subtraction ...
you take these two, you take these two ...
Let's see how I can draw it nicely.
So, we take p from x and pull out of it q from x.
Again we get a lot,
so this will give us ...
We remain in the multitude of the multitudes.
You have a lot of things at any time
and you may be more used to talking about it
with respect to integers
or a number of numbers, but you can talk about it in general.
Here we are talking about the multitude of the multitudes
and we have just seen that if we start with two multi-
two members of the multitude of the ...
Let me be clear, these are multifaceted,
many, those here.
You take two members of the crowd
and perform the subtraction action
and you will again get a member of the crowd.
And when you have a situation like this,
I could call this one,
I do not know, the letters have ended.
Ok, let's just call it f from x,
so here we get f from x.
When you have such a situation you take
two members of one set, apply action on them
or you take a certain number of members from one set,
apply action on them
and again you get a member of the crowd,
we would say that this set is closed in this action.
We could say that the crowd
of polynomials, the plurality of polynomials,
is closed,
closed ...
I will not even put it in quotes.
Closed on subtraction.
And I did not prove it here, I just made an example,
in which I pulled out two multiples
and I got another.
Clearly, there is more accurate evidence you can do.
But this is actually the case, if you have
two multiples, apply subtraction
and you will get another multiplier.
And the modern way to say it is that the plurality of polynomials
is closed at subtraction.
This concept of closing something looks like this
very modern mathematical idea, but it is not too modern.
It's just taking two members from one set,
to apply an action
and if you still get a member of this crowd
after the action, then this set is closed
in this action.